園長の女の子が一人も覚えたさないというのは必要だよね。どうしたんですか?
その当時は、新庄さんの前は誰だったんですか?
新庄さんは、ちょっと思いつかないですか?
新庄さんは、お腹の中になりまして、ライブ前に。
馬のトレーニングは、日本でどういう風に始まるのか?
高烈な施設に行けなければ、何か?
僕たちは、競馬は大体日本だと、走らせた馬をもらってきて、あるいは買ってきて、それをさっきの長馬作でどれどれ。
そうじゃないか。
まずは、長馬作をやるんですけど、最初は暴れますから。
そうですよね。
まず、長馬作でちゃんと回るように踏んで、それで人を乗せて、落とさがりかじるか、何度もやるんですよ。
クロスのボールを飛ばして、1個飛んだらまた次にまたクロスを作ってジャンプ、ジャンプ、ジャンプ、って3回くらいジャンプさせていく。
それを繰り返し繰り返し、とにかく教えるんですよね。
無理しないで、ひっくりしようからからやっていって、だんだん上げていって。飛んだら褒めて、ニージ上げて。
ここはだいたい人情者に座って、やり方全部座って、絶対引っ張られちゃダメだよ。
馬が飛んだら褒めて、飛んだら褒めて、それを繰り返すといいのができるから。
ゆっくりゆっくり、ちょうど。
急にこうやってバーを開けちゃうと、外で人を落ちて嫌なようにしちゃう。
飛べるような、ランダムと一回して。
そしたら、本当に。
そうです。
大きな恐怖がありました。